good morning Dennis a trip to kiev's
main post office for European commission
president Ursula Vander lion there to
promote an eu-sponsored exchange scheme
for energy efficient light bulbs
Ukraine's power grid continues to
struggle under regular Russian shelling
meeting President Vladimir zielinski
wonderlion says the eu's 10th round of
Russian sanctions will be announced in
three weeks to coincide with the
one-year anniversary of the full-scale
invasion the plan is to focus once more
foreign
on technology
that can and should not be used by
Russia's War Machine
in particular to close loopholes and
stop components and weapons being sent
to Russia from countries like Iran
zielinski again asked for more powerful
weapons on Friday Washington announced
its latest arms package for Kiev
including rockets that can reach much
further into russian-controlled
territory in Ukraine but on future EU
membership some less encouraging words
for zelenski there no rigid timelines
but there are goals that you have to
reach reforms for example
most notably tackling corruption
zelenski recently fired several top
officials following corruption
allegations Ukraine is one of eight
candidate countries waiting to join the
block
meanwhile the three Baltic EU leaders
whose country's all border Russia have
increased calls for a ban on any Russian
or belarussian athletes competing at
next year's Paris Olympics so a
boycotting is is a Next Step Poland
Sports Minister says he wants Canada and
other Western Nations to threaten a
coordinated boycott unless the
international Olympic Committee puts a
ban in place
Redmond Shannon Global News London